[Applause]
and finally new rule if there's one
thing the johnny depp trial proved it's
that in this world you got to have a
good lawyer
i won't rehash the gory details of the
case but there were some bad stumbles on
this side
while conversely thanks to camille
vasquez johnny's name has been cleared
if not his bloodstream
point being you need a good
representative in court which made me
think where else does that term
representative come up
oh yeah congress
you see in the american political system
the people are represented by two
separate yet equally stupid groups
the republicans who normalize
constitutional crimes and the democrats
who pit identity groups against each
other these are their stories
last week an 85 percent latino
congressional district on the border
with mexico which had always voted
heavily democratic flipped to the red
team and the campaign manager for the
losing democrat said we gave up a
reliably democratic congressional seat
for no reason at all we deserve to know
why
well aside from your terrible attitude
i'm gonna tell you why because these
voters stop seeing your candidate as
their lawyer
that's why
their message to you was i'm an american
now
i'm here be my lawyer not the lawyer for
the migrants showing up in my backyard
ever
every month i see a new poll reporting
how much latinos despise the woke term
latinx it's about as popular with them
as a reboot of speedy gonzalez
even the country's oldest latino civil
rights group came out against it yet aoc
keeps defending it saying gender is
fluid language is fluid yes and latino
voters are fluid
and more of them now than ever are
identifying as republican
so our asian americans whose support for
democrats is down 16 points since the
last election
a lot of that is because in the name of
achieving equity in schools democrats in
deep blue cities have made it a mission
to eliminate the advanced programs at
which asian kids excel
asian parents said
okay i wish all kids well not a racist
but
i need someone who acts like my lawyer
if you're a parent and wanted schools to
reopen a lot sooner than they did after
covet shutdowns or think maybe your kid
is getting a bad education partly
because it's nearly impossible to fire a
lousy teacher
yeah you're going to say congratulations
teachers you got yourself a good lawyer
the democratic party's always got your
back 100
but i've noticed my kid is kind of an
idiot
so i may be looking for new
representation
president biden wants to cancel hundreds
of billions of dollars in student debt
okay but the poorer two-thirds of
american kids who don't get a college
degree
are going to say
why should the people who didn't go to
college and make less money subsidize
the people who did go
and make more
you want me to chip in so some liberal
arts college can build a bigger rock
wall
you're not my lawyer
[Applause]
a universal basic income
probably sounds pretty good to a lot of
people struggling without a college
degree and a number of cities have been
running pilot programs in guaranteed
income but the west hollywood program
had to be suspended because it was
unconstitutional they set up a program
where 25 residents were to get a
thousand bucks for 18 months
but only if you identified as lgbt the
rest of that
why
because they need money more than any
other people because no one in west
hollywood will hire a gay person
when he ran in 2020 bernie sanders said
he would legalize marijuana on his first
day as president but that the business
of selling pot would be awarded first to
those who suffered most from the drug
war and you know what i can't argue with
that instinct the drug war
has been a horrendous instrument of
prejudice and punishment for racial
minorities so it seems fair that they
jumped the line for weed franchises the
way indians did for casinos
but it's also what's holding up
republican support for legalizing weed
nationally which would be good for
everybody
and these are the hard practical choices
the democrats have to weigh
redress the past
or reach out to the getable white voter
who says you know what i'd like a shot
at getting in the pot business
but to do that
our entire audience
but to do that i'm going to need a good
lawyer who fights for me
and then there's abortion
a difficult issue for the democrats to
lose on but they're trying
for decades liberals have said if only
men could get pregnant this wouldn't
even be an issue
and abortion rights are women's rights
well that's wrong now or as the kids say
hold up
when the wokey end of the progressive
spectrum talks about abortion now they
shy away from that word women and prefer
terms like birthing people
or people who menstruate because
somewhere there's a trans man who's
pregnant and i say good for him and i'll
be
and i'll be looking for his story
somewhere in a future issue of ripley's
believe it or not
oh democrats let's take the first
[ __ ] word a human animal understands
mama
and replace it with something best
understood by four trotskyites at
berkeley
as with all these issues the wavering
voter is saying to her lawyer the
democratic party hey so happy for you
that you have so many other clients
and that you care so much about their
problems and all the pro bono work you
do but you're supposed to be my lawyer
the democrats need to be like the
lawyers you see on billboards you hurt
we fight
injured get the gorilla
minzy makes them pay
and my favorite just because you did it
doesn't mean you're guilty
it doesn't
i think it does
but that's the thing about a lawyer
their clients don't care if they shade
the truth they care about winning
you know what i want the democratic
party to do win
on the trump issue finish what you
started with the january sixth hearings
and make sure the guy who absolutely
will try to steal the next election
can't run in it that's what i want my
lawyer to do
you